- It was 50 years ago.
When you draw one frame,
you can eat one ramen,
but the rate of their life increase.
- The inflation.
- Yeah.
So now if you want to eat a ramen,
you have at least to
do five or six frames.
- Oh my gosh.
- Am I allowed to ask you
what that might be per frame?
- Well, when you're in-betweener,
you are paid like-
(chill music plays)
- Hello and welcome to another
episode of "Trash Taste,"
the anime podcast, where
we talk about Japan,
food, shitting, and occasionally anime.
I was trying to remember
what I said last week.
(everyone laughs)
- Is that what you said last week?
- I think that's what I said last week.
I am your host for today, Garnt again.
And joining me is as usual the boys.
And once again, we have
a guest as I'm hosting.
We have a Ken Arto.
Do you want to introduce
yourself and what you do?
- Yes.
Nice to meet you.
My name is Ken Arto.
I am a key animator in Japan since 2015.
And so I had work on projects
like "Dragon Ball Super Broly,"
"My Hero Academia,"
"JoJo," a lot of things.
- [Connor] Yes.
- And-
- Sorry, I just love "JoJo."
- And I am a key animator at Studio 4C.
- Oh, okay.
Wow.
Well, we have a quick spread
of some of the shows you've worked on.
Not everything.
- [Joey] Wow, you worked
on "Monsters University?"
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah.
I like pretty much shonen jump, so yeah.
- Yeah, I mean, obviously
this isn't all the shows
that Ken's worked on, but you know,
these are probably I'd
say the most notable ones.
I mean, there's obviously
more like, you know,
the recent "Jujutsu Kaisen."
- "Jujutsu Kaisen."
- Episode 16, right?
- 16.
That would be this Friday.
And recently also
"Kimetsu No Yaiba Movie."
- Oh my God.
Just casually drop that.
- That's one hell of a CV.
Well, thank you very much for coming on
because it's nice to have someone
who's actually been
working in the industry
and is knowledgeable
about what it's actually
like working in there
instead of just having three
guys sitting in the room
just taking guesses, taking pot shots.
- We just take, you know,
knowledgeable guesses.
Sometimes not knowledgeable guesses.
- I think when we don't have a guest,
it's like don't listen to what we say.
We don't know what we're talking about.
- But now we're literally
like first hand source.
- Now we can get the answers
at the same time as our audience.
- I am curious if there was,
you know, perhaps one scene
or one show that you would recommend
for someone to watch to maybe
experience your work the best,
what would you point them towards?
- Actually I would maybe say,
I'm working on a movie for Studio 4C.
I can't say the name 'cause it's not.
Actually, yeah, this
movie I put all my guts,
and so yes, you have to
wait a bit, but yeah.
- That was the most slick
way to promote the new movie.
(everyone laughs)
"My best work is one
that you're gonna have
"to go see in cinemas."
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, "Jujutsu Kaisen" episode 16,
I think it's a good shot I have done so.
- I mean, how long have you been working
in the industry now?
- So, we don't count my internship,
it will be now five years.
And so I start as in-betweener.
So to...
- Between frames, right?
- Between frames.
Clean the in-betweens.
And I have done just
for one year and half.
And after I have switch of schedule,
I went to Yapiko Animation.
And the previous was at Graphinica.
And Yapiko, Yapiko I made
so two year and half.
And after Yapiko, now I am at Studio 4C.
- [Connor] Studio 4C.
- 'Cause like its,
'cause your background is
that you're half Japanese,
half French, right?
- Yeah.
- So was like, what made
you want to start working
in the anime industry?
- Actually in France, we have in the 90s
and a show called "Club Dorothee."
And actually, Dorothee was a woman
who bought a lot of anime.
And "Dragon Ball," "Saint
Seiya," "Maison Ikkoku," "Ranma."
And so when I was little,
I watched those shows,
and also I went often
to Japan with my mother.
And yeah, I was used to watch
a lot of anime when I was kid.
And I grew with manga also, and so, yeah,
I used to draw those
characters when I was little.
And so, at first I wanted to be a mangaka.
- As does everyone I think.
I think every weeb has had that dream
one time in their lives.
- No.
- Every weeb who draws their
first anime character's like,
"Yeah, I'm on my way
to be on shonen jump."
(everyone laughs)
"Let's go."
- Are you telling me, Connor,
that you've never had like a story
or something that you've
just like, fantasized about?
- No.
- You never fantasized as a kid at all?
- Probably.
But I probably, that was
like my thing, right?
I'm not sharing it with other people.
It's my story, you know what I mean?
I'm not sharing it.
- You never had a phase
where you were like,
oh, I guess though like you
started watching anime, like,
a little bit of like an older stage.
- That's true.
- 15, 16 I started watching
anime. So pretty late I think.
I probably didn't get
that whimsical phase of-
- Yeah 'cause I mean, how
old were you when you, like,
first, like, really, I guess like,
while knowing that this is anime?
- Oh, I don't remember.
I think the shock I had was in '98
when I watch "Princess Mononoke."
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- And for the same,
I didn't know what I'm
watching, but it was beautiful.
Scary and beautiful.
And I was just nine.
- Just nine.
- Yeah, just nine.
And also when I watch
"Evangelion" I was just 10 or 11.
- What?
Did you understand anything?
- Oh, hey, same here actually.
Same.
I'm glad somebody-
- I don't know if I was
understanding everything,
but oh, there is mecha, there is alien.
Okay, they have to beat them.
(everyone laughs)
- That's all you, like,
understand about "Eva"
when you're like 10.
It's like good guys, bad guys.
- I mean, I'll be honest.
I watched it last year
and that's pretty much my understanding.
(everyone laughs)
- Also the character was 14
on the story and I was 11 so-
- Close enough, right?
- Yeah, close enough.
- [Joey] Yeah, true, true.
- Okay, I can pilot.
- It's gonna be me.
- Maybe I can be in the EVA.
- I actually have a similar
story about like "Eva"
'cause "Eva" is the second
proper anime that I watched
after discovering it was anime.
So, the first anime I ever watched
knowing it was an anime was "Naruto."
And how I found that was I
was on a random gaming forum,
and you know, it was back
when having anime avatars
was actually cool.
(everyone laughs)
You know?
And I was like, "What are
these avatars that people have?
"They look really cool."
And I found that one guy had this avatar
that was from the show called "Naruto."
And I'm like, "Oh, this kind
of looks like Dragon Ball Z."
Watched "Naruto," fucking loved it.
Introduced me to anime properly.
And then I went on the same gaming forum,
and I made it like an anime thread.
I was like, "Guys, this
Naruto thing is awesome.
"Can you guys recommend
to me something else
"to watch like Naruto?"
And some guy deadass goes,
"You should watch Evangelion.
"Totally like Naruto."
- Totally.
- So, I went into "Evangelion,"
I was like an 11, 12 year old,
thinking it was a shonen anime.
- Oh my God.
- And so for like the
first I'd say half of it,
it could like maybe have
like passed as a shonen
because, you know, Shinji
could have still, you know,
Shinji was still doing stuff.
And then the halfway point hit,
and then everyone just
got sad and depressed.
And my 11 year old mind was just like,
"Why are people like this?
"This is so stupid.
"This is so unrealistic."
I remember thinking as an 11 year old,
the writing of the show is so bad
because the adults don't
have their shit together.
Why is that?
So why don't the adults
have their shit together?
This is so unrealistic.
- Imagine, like, 11 year old Garnt going
up to his mom being like,
"Mother, what is depression?"
(everyone laughs)
"I learnt it in this
show called Evangelion."
- And now I'm just like,
"Oh yeah, so adults just,
"no adults just have their together.
"That's just life."
- So you've always been
able to speak Japanese
since a young age?
- Yes, it was my mother.
And so, yes, I learned,
I don't know if I can say I learned-
- But you just know it?
- Yeah, I just know.
With anime, with drama, with movies,
and my mother and some of my family.
Like I said, it's a family language.
So when you have to work,
you use another Japanese
language which is keigo.
- [Connor] Oh God.
- And so yes-
- Keigo is like very formal Japanese?
- Very formal.
When you have to spoke with
your senpai, with your boss.
It's different.
You have to put your
interacter up and you're down.
- Basically it's the bane of every, like,
person trying to learn Japanese.
It's smooth sailing until you hit keigo.
And then everyone's like, "I give up."
- Smooth sailing until you hit keigo?
- Oh no, trust me.
- Oh, fuck off.
- If you think it's hard
now, wait 'til you hit keigo.
- I've just given up on the
thought of ever learning keigo.
I'm like, keigo?
I'm okay.
- Because I thought that as well.
'Cause I kind of was the
same thing where I'd like,
you know, I don't speak
keigo to my parents.
I don't think any kid does.
So I had to learn keigo on
the job when I first started,
like, you know, part-time jobs in Japan.
And I was like, I thought I knew Japanese.
I'm told I had to start using keigo.
It just threw every
conception about Japanese
out the window.
- Is there like any comparison
that's even close to English with keigo?
- It's like, oh man.
I don't know, is there a comparison?
- Would it be like trying
to speak a very old,
like, very posh kind
of version of English?
- It's kinda like going from
only learning internet slang
to learning Shakespeare.
- I see.
- It's basically another language.
- So you motherfuckers have
to learn to speak in cursive.
- Pretty much, yeah.
(everyone laughs)
We literally like, it's like
a Shakespeare play, you know,
when the translation is on the page.
It's basically that.
(everyone laughs)
- I saw there was like Japanese cursive.
- Is there?
- Like, yeah, I saw that
someone was writing Japanese
in cursive.
- Oh, maybe like calligraphy, right?
- No, no, no.
Like, legit.
Like, it was like a doctor's
note someone had showed me
and it was-
- Oh no, dude.
Every time I have to
go to the doctors here,
I'm just like, I might as well die
'cause I can't read this note.
- It's good to know that
that transcends language,
that doctors just can't write for shit.
(everyone laughs)
Somehow that's-
- It's universal.
- Yeah, and I thought kanji was hard,
but you throw in cursive
kanji and I'm like, come on.
- It's like level 100 comprehension.
(everyone laughs)
- Actually when you have some animators,
you have some notes of my sempai on paper.
I try to read it.
(everyone laughs)
Because what did he?
I don't.
- It's like decoding it.
- I have to decode but
it takes too much time,
so I'll go to my senpai,
"Sorry, what did you write?"
- "What the fuck is this?"
- It's just easier to ask, isn't it?
- Yeah.
- So was it anime that,
I'm guessing it was anime,
the reason you started to
learn animation and really-
- At first I think,
so, I wanted to be mangaka,
but I was not good at school.
(everyone laughs)
Not good at school.
And well, you have lessons,
but I didn't listen to lesson.
I was drawing manga on my notes.
And so I went to another
school, not a high school.
A high school where you could
learn about communication,
art craft-
- This is in France, right?
- Yeah, in France.
I was born and raised in France.
And at first it was about communication,
how to do commercial.
And it was not pleasant,
but I had to go this way
to go to animation schools.
- Right, right, right.
- So I take to baccalaureat in French.
So first degree I think.
- Oh, bachelor.
- Bachelor, yes.
- So you did a bachelor's
degree in animation.
- Bachelor.
And after I went to animation school.
- Oh, wow.
So, how did that transition
from that in France
to being in Japan?
'Cause I feel like that's
like a big leap, right?
- When you're at art school in France,
in France anime wasn't,
it was popular,
but for adults, it's what kind of-
- What kind of child
nonsense is this, yeah.
- This and, "Oh, you
should change some style.
"It's not a good style."
(everyone laughs)
You have others who
watching you from up and,
"Change the style.
"You're drawing too much manga.
"It's not that bad, but it's manga."
And so, yeah, I was okay.
If I draw manga, it's bad things.
So I changed my style.
But I actually, I wanted
to draw manga style.
- I feel like in Europe, there
is the notion of animation is
especially anime looks for children.
Because I feel like everyone I spoke to
who grew up in Europe seems
that way where it's like,
"Oh, after I'm 16 I can't
watch this child stuff."
- Yeah.
- Every art student I know, like,
I have a cousin who's an art student,
and she loves anime.
But as soon as she started art school,
you were just like,
it was looked down upon to
really draw an anime art style.
So I don't know if it's still the same-
- Weebs getting bullied
everywhere they go.
- Exactly.
'Cause like you draw anime,
and your your art teacher would
just be like, "No, no, no.
"Please, draw real art."
- Some arts professor of arts school.
"Oh, you drew a manga.
"Okay, I will give you
a bad note, bad score."
- You have to change.
- Or draw some American comics, good.
(everyone laughs)
So yes, it is not some equals
by some professor, teacher.
So yeah, it was kind of
harder the first time
because you are a bit lost.
"Okay, I have to change my style."
But when you met other people
who like what you like too,
you have a better communication,
and you know, I want to do this
I want to draw anime style.
- I wanna be a weeb.
(everyone laughs)
- I want to follow my dreams.
- And so, yeah.
And I found that, there's an
animation school in France.
And so I attempt to, I
went to animation school.
But you rely on Disney way.
- Right, right, right.
- Not Japanese way because
Japanese way is very particular
where you use economy,
economy of the frame.
Very smart, it's a smart way
to use a Japanese animation.
In Disney you have a lot of budget,
so you can put a lot of frames.
- [Joey] Right, right, right.
- Throw money at the problem.
- So basically Disney
is just more drawings
where the Japanese animation
technique is more, let's say-
- Optimized?
(everyone laughs)
- I was looking for the right word.
- Because also Japanese
animation industry,
you have to do one episode per week.
So maybe in America, they finished
and they delivered the
episodes to the channel.
But in Japan when you broadcast
the show, it's not finished.
You're trying to work out.
- Yeah, 'cause I've noticed
that a lot of blu-ray
releases have like retouches.
Like, "Jojo" I remember part four,
there's some famous
examples of the side by side
where you can like,
there's a website I think
where you can sweep the frame across.
And like some of the character
designs are totally changed
in the blu-ray.
- Yeah, that's called DVD retakes.
And actually when you saw your show on TV.
And so for people who want to buy the DVD,
that is a plus and the plus, it's a bonus,
is a better drawings or
the animation redone.
- More polished.
- So, is it like the original
drawing is thrown out
and they just remake it
or do they improve the original drawing?
- Improve or sometimes they redo it.
- Oh, wow.
- So it's quite tense.
- Oh, we can't do a 100
person like we wanted.
So, let's redo it.
Oh, this one,
I just mess up on the eyes
or let's redraw the eyes.
- Right, right, right.
Wow.
- I did find that funny
actually, because like, yeah,
I noticed that like, 'cause, you know,
when I did voice work for "Pop Team Epic"
I did it on episode nine.
And when I got the script for it,
episode one had already aired,
so I was like, "Is this
gonna be out in time?"
(Connor laughs)
'Cause I always thought it worked like how
in American TV shows
where it's like the entire
season is already done.
It's done and then they
start releasing it.
But in Japan they're just like,
"Nope, we got to do it now."
It's all real time.
- It depends.
When the first episode is broadcast,
actually so you have might
have done already 10 episodes.
If the schedule was good.
Or if they have done just four episode,
it would be harder.
(everyone laughs)
- I love how 10 episodes is
considered a good schedule.
- Yeah, exactly.
Have you ever been
working up to the deadline
where you've been working on the show
and it's been airing at that point?
- It was for "Hero Aca."
I think season three.
I was doing my genga.
So, yeah, a genga is the second
step of the key animation.
And-
- What does genga involve?
- Okay.
- Connor knows nothing about animation,
so we're gonna break it down.
- For now I will explain the process
of the fabrication of genga.
So you have the key animator, me,
I received an offer of
work by Twitter or by mail.
- By Twitter?
- Sometimes by Twitter.
Because a lot of assistant
production looking
for animators on Twitter.
And so for Japan, most
of the Japanese animator
they use Twitter as a portfolio, contact.
- Tons of DM, right?
Okay, that makes sense.
- And so, "Hi, I'm from this studio,
"I have this project.
"The schedule is that, do
you want to work on it?"
So I look my schedule.
If it's okay, if it's
good match, "Yeah, sure."
"Okay, let's put a date for the meetings."
So okay, this date.
So I go to the schedule,
meet at the place they said,
and assistant production who I send mails,
and we are doing the meeting
for the sequence I have choose.
At first, they send me a storyboard.
A storyboard is a little
comic, technical comic about-
- [Connor] It's like a rough outline
of how the scene would go, right?
- Yes.
With the camera walks, technical notes.
And I choose my sequence.
A sequence can be just like three cut,
30 cuts, 19 cuts.
- What's a cut?
- A cut is one scene.
- Like one scene,
like one continuous scene-
- Oh, I see.
- Camera changes or the scene changes.
- So, you know, when in live action
when you film something
and then the camera cuts,
obviously in animation you
don't have an entire scene
that you cut out of that's preplanned.
- Right, right, that makes sense.
- And so one scene can be one second
or 10 second, 30 second.
It depends.
And if there is a lot of
seconds, it's more work.
- Right, right, naturally.
- And so let's take an example.
Okay, we choose this sequence.
It's 10 cuts.
And so I go to the meeting,
the meeting with the director,
and he going to explain me how he see,
how he want those 10 cuts made.
And he speak to me,
"Yeah, for this cut, I would
like a rough animation,
"a more action, like a form of West coast
"or we'll say sakuga."
(everyone laughs)
- Sakuga.
- Sakuga is like the Western slang word
for like good animation.
- Yeah, so the word
sakuga in Western world is
completely different to what
sakuga in Japanese actually is.
- Yeah.
- So in the anime community,
we refer to sakuga as
good animation, right?
Like lots of frames,
lots of flashy animation.
But in Japanese sakuga just means frames.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- You look at the kanji
saku make, that picture.
- So it's kind of become
like a buzz word here.
- Yeah, that makes sense.
- Like, if you said anime in Japan.
Anime is animation.
But if you say anime in West, it's-
- Only Japanese anime.
- It's only Japanese anime.
- So in Japan, "Monsters
Inc" is technically an anime.
- Yes.
(everyone laughs)
- My anime list, hello, hello.
- So you had, like, 10 cuts
on "My Hero Academia" to do.
All different types of animation.
- Different types of animation.
Sometimes just the talkings,
little actings,
and sometimes some action cuts.
And so I do the meeting with the director.
So it takes like 30 minutes.
After, so I have to do the
first step is the layout.
So I'm going to explain what is this.
- Yes, please.
You're telling me words
and I have no idea.
(everyone laughs)
Tell me what the layout is.
- Layout is, so you have the storyboard,
I see the one scene
and I have to draw the background
with a character on it,
or the movement of the
character, just rough.
- Very rough, okay.
- Very rough.
And also if there is a camera
walks, I have to add it.
And put the timing of this cuts.
- Oh, wow, okay.
- So it's basically like the storyboard
but just a bit more refined.
- Refined.
With you see the character,
what movement he will do.
- Oh, like when you see
those outline sketches.
- Yeah, like that.
And you don't need to push it to the most.
So you have to watch your drawings,
you have to know a bit
of what the character is-
- The armor or clothes.
- Exactly.
And when you finish that,
you send it back to the director.
Your director will check
it, add some correction.
Oh, the arm is too low, more higher.
The expression not sad, more angry.
And after those correction
by the director,
it will go to the sakan.
So, sakuga kantoku.
It means animation director.
And the animation director
will put your drawings more
in model.
So if you have see good drawing,
it's because of the sakan
have put all his guts on it.
Because the sakan,
in one episode there
is at least one or two
and here they have to check the 150 cuts.
- [Connor] Oh wow.
- So, they basically make sure
that the characters kind of look the same
and consistent throughout.
- In fact, the animators
just draw a rough diamond.
And if the diamond is good quality,
after the sakan can polish it.
- Right, right.
- So like, so like how many, like,
say for like "My Hero Academia,"
like an episode of "My Hero Academia,"
like, how many different
animators would be working
on like one episode for instance?
Like, individual animators?
- I think maybe-
- On average.
- On average at least 10
animators would be good.
But you can see on the credits
how many animators genga, it called genga.
How many animators sometimes.
You have 15 animators.
Or sometime you have what
is called one man army.
(everyone laughs)
Just one guy.
- One guy for an entire episode.
- Wow!
- Have you ever done that?
- Oh no, no, no.
Actually I'm just a baby, man.
I'm just a baby animator.
- I was gonna say like-
- How much of a machine do you have to be
to do the sakuga of an
entire 24 minute episode.
- Yeah, and those guys are monsters.
- Are their hands just like red?
Like, just destroyed?
- Their wrists are just like this thick.
- Very fast.
You see, this is Japanese animation
when you see a veteran
animator who show you-
- Imagine one guy doing it all.
- It's like that scene
from "Hunter x Hunter"
where the guy returns from,
like, being up in the mountains
for, like, 10 years or something.
- Oh, Netero.
- Yeah, when Netero just returns.
And he just shows everyone how it's done.
And everyone becomes his disciples.
- Something that would
take me like one day,
they can do it in one hour.
- Oh my God.
Some people have too much talent.
It ain't right.
- Also with me I'm just, I'm 31.
And the guy, my senpai, has
like 31 years of experience
in animation.
I'm just a baby.
- So, five years in the anime
industry is like nothing.
- It's nothing.
- Wow.
Oh my God.
(everyone laughs)
We'll have you back on in 20 years.
- It's like, "Yes, I can
do a cut in an hour now.
"What of it?"
- So sorry, going back earlier as well,
way earlier in the conversation, I guess,
you said you learned in France.
And I am curious
'cause we jumped back
into talking about anime.
How did you then make the leap
to when you're done with art school
and plans to go to Japan?
- So because I was in animation school,
we have to then do internship.
And so I asked my school
if it was possible to go to
Japan to do my internship.
They said, "Yes, if you
find a studio by yourself."
And so, my first internship was,
oh boy, 10 years ago.
(everyone laughs)
In 2011.
And so I have sent a lot of mails.
20, 25.
- Bringing out the keigo.
- He's a good mate.
My mother helped me-
(everyone laughs)
- I've been there.
- So for the proper
forms and my portfolio.
And so yeah, I had just five answers
and four no and one yes.
- Oh.
- That's all you need, isn't it?
- At least they're courteous
enough to reply with a no
'cause most job interviews
or most job place I apply to,
a no is just not hearing back.
- Yeah.
And I was so happy,
but in March you had the-
- Oh, yeah.
- And so they asked me,
"Do you really want to come to Japan?"
And I didn't know, what will
my future will be for me
and for me it was a unique chance.
So I said, "Yeah, definitely."
And the studio was Telecom Animation Film.
- Oh, okay.
- They have made "Castle of Cagliostro."
- Yeah.
- First movie of Miyazaki Hayao.
- I think most recently didn't
they make "Tower of God?"
- Yes.
- I think that's the most recent
one I remember them making.
- This episode is sponsored by ExpressVPN.
- You know what I like doing, gentlemen?
- What?
- Shitting.
Especially shitting privately.
- That's a controversial take.
- I know.
Now imagine if you just
couldn't shit privately
and your door was always open.
Well, that's what it's
like not using ExpressVPN.
- I actually like shitting
with the door open.
- I didn't need to know.
- It's claustrophobic!
Did you know that your
internet service provider
like Comcast or Verizon
knows every single website
you visit?
- Now that's not cool.
- [Connor] And what's worse is
that they can sell this
information to ad companies
and tech giants who will
use your data to target you.
- Luckily ExpressVPN
can put a stop to that.
It creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet
so that your online activity
can't be seen by anyone.
- I use ExpressVPN on all my devices.
It works on everything.
Phones, laptops, even routers.
Yes, I said routers
'cause that's how I was taught to say it.
Is it router or router?
- I say router.
- I'm router as well.
- Router gang rise up!
- Router gang, woo!
So, everyone who shares your
wifi can still be protected
even if they don't have ExpressVPN.
- I've put it on my bidet.
- Did you?
- No.
But I'd like to if I could.
And the best part is using
ExpressVPN is as easy
as closing the bathroom
door, which I don't do.
You just fire up the app,
click the button, and you're protected.
- ExpressVPN is the world's
number one rated VPN by CNET,
Wire, the Verge, and countless others.
So if you're like me
and believe your online
activity is your business.
I see what they did there.
They're referring to shitting.
Secure yourself by visiting
ExpressVPN.com/TrashTaste today.
That's ExpressVPN.com/TrashTaste.
- And you can get an extra
three months for free!
- That's ExpressVPN.com/TrashTaste.
Link's down in the description below.
Thank you for the sponsor.
Back to the video.
- So what did you have
to do at your internship?
What was that like?
- So at first they, I have some,
one, no two weeks of
experience of how to do a work,
how a character do a rotation of the head.
So exercise, it would
be exercise on paper.
- Okay.
- And so at first, "Oh, I know that."
But, like I said, I know the Western-
- The Disney way.
- I didn't know the Japanese way.
Less frame,
just some key pose and after
you do the in-betweens.
But I had to key poses,
and I have to clean up these key poses
and do the in-between frames.
- So, the in-between frames,
I assume as they say,
like in the name, right?
- Do you want to explain key frames
and in-betweens to Connor?
- So this is one.
- Yeah.
- Two.
For a punch, one, two.
But, I need some in-betweens to maybe.
This the key pose.
In-betweens.
Key pose.
- And the in-betweens are
normally not as polished as the?
- So, the in-betweens,
you have to take the two key poses and to-
- [Connor] Layer them?
- Layer them and you do the
in-betweens then like that.
- [Connor] Oh, okay.
- It's basically like the plugin
and after effects that
people put over their anime
to make it 60 FPS,
but someone's actually
doing that themselves.
That's the best way I can describe it.
- In Japan, we took 24 FPS.
- 24.
- And that's the in-between
frames are normally given to,
like, interns.
- Yes.
At first, you know, when you start,
you start has a dulgaman.
So dulga is moving, it
means moving pictures.
But it's mainly in-between in Japan.
And so I had done this for two weeks
and after just two weeks,
they put me on productions.
- [Connor] Oh wow.
- And it was-
- Two weeks into your internship?
- Wow.
- Two weeks of exercise.
And the last two months and half,
it was on the production of "Lupin."
- Oh my God.
I thought you'd be getting
coffee or something.
Two weeks in working on "Lupin."
- They really put you to work.
(everyone laughs)
- So, it was two weeks of exercise.
And after two months and half on "Lupin."
It was a TV special, so a TV show.
And yes, it was my first experience.
And so I met a lot of famous
animators, a lot of veterans,
and the staff was very nice to me.
It was at Mitaka.
- Right.
- Yeah, the stuff was very nice.
Wondering, "Why do you go to Japan?"
(everyone laughs)
No.
And yeah, I wanted to go.
I want to work in Japan.
- Yeah, you want to be
an animator for anime.
Man, I feel bad for our intern now.
(everyone laughs)
Like, we're sorry, Ashley.
Like, hearing this story, you know.
(Garnt laughs)
- And I had met a senpai, a French senpai
who by the name of Christophe Ferreira.
- The most French name I've
ever heard. (Garnt laughs)
- And he said to me, take
time and a work very late.
And when you work very late,
there are less animators
but the boss is not here.
And so anyway, he says,
they are more free to speak to you.
- More socializing going on.
- Yeah, more socializing at night.
Oh, you work harder, very late.
What are you doing?
- I feel like that must be
your bonding experience, right?
'Cause you're staying up late together.
- Exactly.
When most of my good animators friends was
because yes, we work very at,
at eight o'clock in the
morning because we work hard.
We didn't slept.
"And your my brother now."
(everyone laughs)
- My man!
- Damn so, you literally just
sent an email to a company
and then you flew to Japan and wow.
- And then he worked on fuckin' "Lupin."
- Literally within a month.
So, what timeframe was it from you sending
that email to the company
to you being in Japan
working on "Lupin the Third?"
- Yeah.
So I sent email in January.
They said, "okay."
And so I went in June.
- Wow.
- Like, six months.
- Six months.
- That's crazy.
- But yes, but I was pretty lucky
because the director said yes
and now the director is no more
working at Telecom Animation
because he's now in Thai.
And yeah, so it was cool.
And so this was my first experience
in the Japanese animation industry.
It was 10 years ago.
And so I went to another animation school.
And to this animation school,
I had the occasion to do a
summer school at Gobelins.
L'Ecole de L'Image.
It's a French famous school for animation.
And I had met Thomas Romain.
He's very famous
because he's maybe the top
of French animators in Japan.
And also because he's very famous,
he redrew his kids' drawings.
- [Garnt] Oh, I might've-
- [Connor] That sounds familiar.
- That sounds very familiar.
That sounds like he blew up
on the Reddit or something.
- Yeah, so his kids drew,
and he picked a picture of his kids
and redrew it as a professional.
- Yeah, that sounds very familiar.
Yeah.
- I met him at this summer school.
And I talk a bit with him,
and he gave me his cards, business cards.
And connection is very important.
- Yeah.
- Like I said, this summer
school, I could do it
because in fact a director
of Telecom Animation
was doing summer school at Gobelins,
but he needed a translator.
- Oh.
- And he called me.
He goes, "Oh, you're in
France, you can help me."
- [Connor] Right, right, right.
- And that's why,
the first way to find a
contact is very difficult.
But when you have one, he can
introduce you to someone else.
- Yeah, the door opens.
- But that's what it is with,
like, the anime industry is
that, like, it's only so big.
So once, you know, one person-
- The hard part is getting in,
but everyone I've met who is
working in the anime industry
especially if they're a foreigner,
they've just had like that
one lucky pull of, like,
just like the one lucky in.
And once they've got that in.
- As new animators the first
time it's difficult to enter
but after it's to stay.
(everyone laughs)
But so, I sent a mailer to Thomas Romain.
And Thomas Romain was working
at this time at Satelight.
So, they're very famous
for the series "Macross."
- Another animation studio, I assume?
- Yeah.
- They made "Log Horizon"
as well, season...
One of the seasons.
- Season two?
- And so I could manage to
do a four month internship
at Satelight.
But it was very different from Telecom.
It was a bit more colder,
a bit more rush.
"Oh, hurry up, hurry up."
At Telecom the animators were coming at 10
and leaving at night or like at 10 or so.
But at Satelight, everybody
was coming in the afternoon,
two or four, and was working at 6:00 AM.
- Oh my God.
Jesus.
- Definitely a lot more like hardcore.
I guess, like, what I
want to ask is, like,
kind of going back to
"Lupin the Third" thing.
Like, I assume you, like,
watched the TV show
after it came out, right?
- Yeah.
- I've always wanted to
know, like, as an animator,
like, how does it feel to see something
that you drew be animated on TV?
'Cause like, I can't
imagine what that's like.
- So sometimes you, "Oh, shit I screw up."
(everyone laughs)
I find, like, there are,
I managed to do something good.
When some few weeks
passed, look at it again.
(Garnt laughs)
You're not very satisfied.
- That's how you know you've grown, right?
You hate everything you've made.
- The way for to grow in
drawings is very difficult
because it's not like that,
it's like stairs.
- Right, right, right.
- And sometimes the days
are long flat momentum.
You don't progress.
And yeah, you,
it's a, yeah, you fight against you,
between prov and sometimes
you can depress sometimes.
- But I'm sure there's been moments
where, you know, there was like
a cut that was really good.
And you're just like, "Yeah, I did that."
- Yeah, there is.
There is moment.
And when you have this moment,
it's the moment, "oh
man, animation is cool."
(everyone laughs)
- I think it's the same for us
when we make like a YouTube video.
Sometimes we just feel like
we've stagnated in content.
And sometimes-
- How do I beat this?
- Sometimes we put out that
one banger video and like,
"Yeah, this is why I do YouTube."
And then you hate your job
for the rest of the time.
- And also when you can talk
animation with your senpai
or your coworkers is very good.
And share the things you like.
The way of thinking of
animation is the same as me.
Yeah, it's cool.
And so talking about
animation with your senpai,
and you learn a lot of
history of a famous show.
At this point when they done
this episode, there was broken.
But they managed to succeed it.
- I've gotta ask what's the first show
that you were given that you were, like,
really, really excited for?
Like, when you realize, "Oh,
I'm working on this show?
"Really?
"This show?"
What was the first time?
- "Dragon Ball Super Broly."
- "Dragon Ball," of course!
Of course, I bet it was.
- When I was little, I was
watching "Dragon Ball."
Goku, I was imitating kamehameha.
And so I had, so yeah.
"Dragon Ball," I had
the chance to work on it
because my senpai,
I was at Yapiko at this moment.
And I had start as key animator.
- [Connor] Wow.
- And yeah, so we skip a
lot of years to Graphinica
where I was in-betweener.
So when I was at Yapiko,
my senpai wanted to work on
"Dragon Ball Super," the series.
But so we had another senpai
who had worked on "Restriction F,"
previous movie of "Dragon Ball Super."
- Okay, "Resurrection F."
- And his name is Shimizu...
Oh, I forgot.
- Shimizusan.
(everyone laughs)
- And Hiroshi Shimizu.
He used to do character for
days I know for manga books.
- Oh shit.
Okay.
- And he, so he introduced us to Toriya.
"Hey, those French people
want to work on Dragon Ball."
(everyone laughs)
And so Toriya met us and,
"Okay, so we have this episode.
"You have a Vegeta and
a Goku fight these,"
I don't remember the name of the man.
He wears white.
- So someone's just like,
"These guys want to work on Dragon Ball."
And Toriya's literally like, "Yeah, sure."
- We had a recommendation.
Senpai, okay.
So at first, do the series
and if the series was good,
okay, maybe you can work on-
- [Connor] Do more, right.
- On the movie.
And the movie wasn't
announced at this moment.
- Right.
- And so, okay.
Let's work on the episode.
But when they sent us the
storyboard and the schedule,
there was not a good match
because it was the end of December.
And most of the French
people was going back to-
- Christmas.
- Christmas, and so,
"Sorry, can you give us another storyboard
"to finish the episode?"
Okay.
"Well, by the way, how about the movie?"
(everyone laughs)
Sure.
- Just casually throw that-
- So they tested you out on the movie?
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
- What a trial run.
Imagine that.
- And it was the first time
I was doing genga on a movie.
So, I had some pressure
- Some pressure?
- Yeah.
Pressure because you know that
"Dragon Ball" fans can be-
(everyone laughs)
- We've talked about it before.
We've talked about
"Dragon Ball" fans before.
- Are "Dragon Ball" fans the same in Japan
like they are in the West?
Or were you talking about
the West specifically?
- I don't know.
Some people can say bad things.
(everyone laughs)
- It's different when an animator
who worked on the movie is saying it.
- I know right.
- So I had the pressure, but I was happy.
Man, I'm working on "Dragon Ball."
And yes, it's cool.
And so when I was doing my
drawings on "Dragon Ball,"
I would (sings)
(everyone laughs)
I was sitting at this table,
but I was listening "Dragon Ball"
and doing "Dragon Ball" stuff.
- Hyping yourself up.
- And I have my buddy Midia Showi
who was on the schedule and
doing our "Dragon Ball."
- Oh my God.
- So, you went from being an intern
to working on "Lupin"
and then being an in-betweener
to just going straight into
the "Dragon Ball Super-"
- No, no, no.
Of course not.
So, I have done my internship
at Telecom Animation Film
and Satelight.
So I have done two internships.
Six months, if you put it-
- Put it all together.
- And when I finished my school, I said,
okay, I have done two internship.
I know it's hard that
Telicom was a good mood,
at Satelight it was more cold
and you have to more hurry
and you are paid also by frame.
So some money-
- Oh shit.
- Yeah, it's per frame
here rather than per day.
- Am I allowed to ask you
what that might be per frame?
- Well, when you're in-between,
you are paid like two euros per frame.
- Two euros per frame?
- Yeah.
- Holy shit.
- What is that in USD?
- So you would draw a
frame, go to Family Mart,
get a sandwich and you just-
- Yes, I use it.
- It's like three or four bucks US.
- Before tax, right?
- Yeah.
- I assume you wouldn't even make enough
to go for the tax cut.
- So when you take a drink you,
"Okay, can I buy a couple maybe?
"Oh, I have to do more frames."
- So, you're making a conscious choice.
I need to draw more so
that I can eat and drink.
- Okay, so how long would
you say it takes you
to do a frame?
- It depends.
- Depends?
- The frame can be just five minutes.
- Right.
- Some frame can take
you two, three hours.
- Oh my.
That's brutal.
- I mean, this has been a hot button topic
in the industry for a while.
- I think a lot of people do talk
about that animators get paid the least.
- Just hearing it from an
actual animator, just, you know.
- And also because nowadays
the anime getting more details
and more, more lines.
- Has the price gone up?
- More sakuga.
- It was 50 years ago
when you draw one frame,
you can eat one ramen.
- [Connor] Right.
- But the rate of their life increase.
- Inflation.
- Yeah, the price.
- Damn you inflation.
- So now if you want to eat a ramen,
you have at least to do five or six frame.
- Oh my.
- So, if you don't mind me asking,
when you did your internship initially,
how much were you getting paid for that?
And were you living off just that?
- At the first internship I wasn't paid.
- Oh, wow.
- Yeah, but the second
internship I was paid.
- So, it really was like a passion thing.
- Yes, it was a passion thing then.
I was knowing that my
internship you are paid or not,
but I was paid by frame for
my internship at Satelight.
And so I knew, okay, it's really hard.
So I tried to do my best.
But yeah, my best record
when I was in internship was just 150.
- 150 frames?
- Yeah.
- So like $300?
- Oh my God.
For a month of work.
And a specialized job as well.
- So this wasn't my internship.
And so it was on paper.
- So wait, the guy who was
probably cleaning the toilets
at the studio was probably
getting paid more than you.
(Ken laughs)
- Honestly, it's probably true.
- Actually if you work at-
(everyone laughs)
- Just work in your local Family Mart.
- I just want to put it into perspective.
Not trying to diminish any
jobs, but like, I mean,
you know, cleaning a toilet
is not a specialized skill.
- Literally working at McDonald's.
- Especially considering
how art school is, like,
one of the most expensive schools.
- Which is why I'm not trying
to belittle any of the jobs,
we need those jobs.
But like, yeah.
The fact that it is a specialized job.
Your best was 300?
Bruh!
- It was my internship.
So, it was, I had an-
- Still for internship.
That's not enough to live, right?
- But like I said, my mother's Japanese,
I had a family in Japan in Tokyo.
So, yes.
It was cool because my family.
I was living in the
house of my grandmother.
So it was a-
- Oh, okay.
- You didn't have to pay
for, like, rent or anything.
- Yes because I had luck.
But, so I was thinking,
man, for foreign people
if you don't have family.
- Yeah, I was about to say, like-
- Did you have friends who
didn't have family here?
- Yeah.
They could negotiate better than me.
- Right, right, right.
- So that's why you'll have to,
now the good advice is you have to look
at the good studio to
take a lot of information
of each schedule.
How do they pay?
Et cetera.
Yeah, it was just intuition.
So I cannot take example of Satelight,
but I more example on Graphinica,
the studio I was doing in-betweens
but digital in-betweens.
- Right, right, right.
- Digital I was more quicker.
- Okay.
- But was the pay the same?
- The pay was the same.
The pay was the same, but we had a kotaku.
So, you have a little
fixer amount of salary,
and it was at least 400 euros.
- A month?
- A month.
And they ask you to do
300 frames per month.
It was at least do 300 frames.
- At least 300 frames a month?
- Yes.
And so when you success to do 300 frames,
your sort of 300 frames two euros,
you have 600 plus the fixed salary.
- So, it's about 1,000 euros.
- 1,000 euros.
- Still for a specialist
job, that's still quite low.
- Yeah, it's still very low compared
to other specialist jobs.
- But my best record when I
was doing in-betweens was 600.
- 600 frames in a month?
- Yeah, 600 frames a month.
So, 600...
- 1,200 euros.
- So, you can at least have 1,500 euros.
- For an internship that's
probably what $1,500.
That's probably not bad for an internship.
- This wasn't an internship.
- A real job?
Oh, okay.
For a real job that kinda sucks.
- Okay, wow.
- Meilyne's face over there.
- Meilyne's like sweating right now.
(everyone laughs)
- So yes, so most of my coworkers,
"I'm working, I'm living
at my parent's house.
"I'm living with a share house."
So, you have to pay
attention about your money
and how you spend it.
- It's not a glamorous lifestyle.
- No.
You don't live, you survive.
- Right.
I think a lot of people sometimes, like,
I remember I've had people come up to me
'cause I'll be like, with, like,
I remember at Anime
Expo I was with Trigger.
And they were like, "Oh,
they want a job at Trigger."
And I'm like, do you really want a job
where, like, you really
have to work your ass off-
- What are your work hours like
if you don't mind me asking?
- At Graphinica?
- Yeah.
- So I start at 10, and it
depends about the deadlines.
You have some time I arrived
and there are a lot of
cuts, and my senpai,
"Oh, you have to finish
this for this evening."
- [Connor] Yeah.
- At eight.
Okay, so I don't eat lunch.
(Garnt laughs)
- They're very opposite of-
- Literally just eight hours straight.
- And sometimes I have,
"Oh, some good cuts.
"I want to do this.
"Please let me do this.
Okay, I need it in three days.
Oh, fuck.
I won't sleep I guess.
(everyone laughs)
Because I wanted to, it was Pokemon, guys.
So I wanted to work Pokemon and yeah.
- You make an exception
'cause you're like,
"I like Pokemon.
"I'll ruin my life for Pokemon."
- It was blue.
It was the Pokemon generation on YouTube.
- Oh, cool.
Oh, that one.
I know that one.
- Yeah, and it was blue with the,
in Japanese you say Kamex.
I don't know in English.
- Blastoise.
- There's French names
as well, isn't there?
French localized names.
- French name is Tortank.
(everyone laughs)
- Tortank!
That sounds way more
badass than Blastoise.
- I learned about that.
Apparently the French
localizations were, like,
really well done for Pokemon.
Apparently it was
really, really well done.
And all the names were,
like, really well thought out
and to do with, like,
a mix of Japanese and French mythologies.
- I mean, Tortanks sounds-
- Well, that just sounds badass.
- Tortoise but it's a tank.
- That's awesome.
- Wow, that is like the very opposite
of European lifestyle where it's like,
"Oh, it's five?
"Oh, the building's on fire?
"Well it's five o'clock, I'm going home."
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, in-between you
have to be passionate.
You have to love animation.
- I've heard that a lot.
- And also it depends what
kind of experience you want.
If it's just, "Oh, I want to
work just once for this show."
On "Naruto" or "Once Piece," I don't know.
"I just want one, two
years experience in Japan."
No, I wanted to have a career in Japan.
- It depends what experience
you're looking for.
- So you often find people
come into the companies like,
"I only want to be here for
a year or two then go back."
- Yeah.
Sometimes some people have come in Japan
and they had some homesick
because it was the first
time they came in Japan
and the food didn't go well
and they couldn't speak Japanese.
So yeah, and English was so-so.
So yeah, so it was difficult
to make some friends.
And so, yes.
You still hang around the same people, so.
- It's just a completely
different lifestyles.
- Did you know English
before you came to Japan?
- Yeah.
- Oh, okay.
- I was learning English at school.
- I gotta ask because
you grew up in France
and moving you know
about, you know, how much,
well you were telling us earlier
about how much more we can get paid
doing the same job being in France
and also having, let's say,
less work hours as well.
What made you decide to give
that up and move to Japan?
And have like a-
- Yeah, because when I tell
my story of my internship
to my friends, "Ken, do you
really want to go to Japan?"
(Garnt laughs)
"It'd be a real issue because
for me I want to have a life."
I could completely understand, you know.
There is no this is the right way.
No.
Everybody has his way of-
- [Connor] Doing it, right?
- Doing it.
And in my case, I wanted to work
in Japanese animation industry
because I like animation,
I like manga.
And yes, there is something
a bit, sorry, masochist.
(Ken laughs)
- Yeah.
- But yeah, it's the way to learn.
Also, this is kind of-
- It's just purely passion driven.
- It just sounds like
you are doing it purely
for the passion.
- I was gonna say for that
pay, you better be passionate.
(everyone laughs)
- But yes, but I mean, animation,
the two, three years are hard.
So if you want to do a career in Japan,
so you have to speak Japanese.
You can manage to work
in Japan with English,
but just as some few
studios we open the doors
because they have a translator or not.
And, but if you can speak Japanese,
more open doors will be offered to you.
- Yeah, and as we've
established, like, you know,
from your stories is that, you know,
getting to know the people as
well just takes you so far.
- Yeah, it really does seem that like,
if you do speak Japanese,
it's like way easier to
get into the anime industry
than I think people make it out to be.
- It's definitely easy mode, isn't it?
- I mean, it's the same
moving to any country
and joining their industry, right?
- I think 'cause you almost find
that people put, like, the
anime industry on a pedestal.
'Cause it's like, it's the anime industry.
It's mythical, it's Japanese.
We don't know what happens.
But when you talk to people, it's like,
"Oh yeah, I get paid
like two euros a frame."
- That's the thing, and I think, like,
going back to the story
of the guy who, you know,
came up and said that he
wanted to work at Trigger.
Like, guarantee he has no idea-
- No idea what it's like to
actually work in Trigger.
- It's like six o'clock's hit.
He's, like, ready to go home.
And everyone's like, "No, no.
"There's four more hours."
- "The day's just started."
- Because yes, in Japan you
have a (speaks Japanese)
and you, so the studio say,
"Oh, you can leave the studio at eight."
But nobody leave at eight.
(everyone laughs)
- You can leave at eight,
and then you see nobody leaving at eight.
- The clock out times
in Japanese companies is
not an official clock out time.
It's like a suggested clock out time.
- So when I was working at Graphinica,
at first in my mind, I say, one year.
We see how one year will be.
If it's too hard, we'll go back to France.
- Try it out.
- First one year and okay.
I think I could do one year plus.
Like that.
One year, one year, one year, one year.
Now I'm at my five years.
And yes.
Yeah, now I have found a good Studio 4C.
I learn a lot from my senpais.
And yeah, I can do more.
- You could do more?
How much longer do you think though?
Because you said you were 31, right?
Still doing all nighters?
Doing crunch time stuff?
- Yeah, but now my body can not.
(everyone laughs)
- I was gonna say 'cause like
I've just hit my 30s as well.
And man, all nighters, they
definitely hit different.
Your body-
- I'm not even in my 30s,
and I can't do all nighters anymore.
- Because when you're 20,
"Oh, no problem!"
- A few cans of Red Bull, it's easy.
- Staying up 48 hours was like no problem.
- When I was younger
getting your drink at night
and you go to work during
the day, it was okay.
Now (sighs)
(everyone laughs)
- Now it's like, oh, it's 11:00 PM, fuck.
- I definitely do find
that my willpower is overexerting my body.
I'm like, "No, I can do this."
And I'm like dying.
- So you have to push yourself.
And like I said, so it's lots
of hours you are sitting.
And sometime I was,
I don't think feel well
because I had a lot of pain in my feet
because I was-
- Your feet?
- Because I was always sitting, sitting.
And so the amount of water,
water, blood on my ankles was...
- Swollen?
My God.
- That's what happens, you know,
when you're like sitting
in a plane for a long time.
- Oh, I guess it is.
- You can die from that though.
- So I had to get up and walk
because it was too painful.
- This episode of "Trash
Taste" is sponsored by Honey.
- Yes.
- We all shop online.
- And we've seen that promo code field
that taunts us at the checkout.
- Well, thanks to Honey manually searching
for coupon codes is a
thing of the goddamn past.
- Yes.
- [Joey] Honey is a free browser extension
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best ones
that it finds to your cart.
Supporting over 30,000 stores online
that range from sites that
have tech and gaming products
to popular fashion brands
and even food delivery.
- That's epic.
- You know what, Connor?
I actually took your advice
and I bought myself a Dyson.
- I knew it, Garnt.
The suction power on
those things is immense.
- It was the best decision of my life.
I even saved $20 on it.
- Get outta here, Garnt.
Get outta here.
- That's a lot of money.
- I mean, considering the
price of those damn things
you better be saving some money.
Thanks to Honey for
enabling us to save money
on our vacuums for the good suck.
Imagine it, you're shopping
on your favorite website.
I know what it is, don't tell me.
When you're at the checkout,
Honey automatically searches
for all the best coupons.
All you need to do is click apply coupons
and it will find it.
- [Garnt] If Honey finds a working coupon,
you'll watch as the prices just drop.
- [Joey] Honey has found
it's over 17 million members
over $2 billion in savings,
not million, billion.
- That's a lot of Gacha
money that I could-
- You have an addiction, Garnt.
Stop.
- If you already don't have Honey,
you could be straight up
missing on some free savings.
- Wow.
It's literally free to install
and it takes seconds, guys.
And by getting it,
you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting the boys.
- I like that.
- So you can get Honey free today
at JoinHoney.com/TrashTaste.
- That's JoinHoney.com/TrashTaste.
Back to the episode.
- Yeah, I guess going off of that,
I want to ask like, you know,
obviously you draw God knows
how many hours per day, right?
Like, I'm sure you've
run into like, you know,
injuries and like wrist problems.
Like, is there, like,
certain stuff that you do
to make sure you don't hurt yourself?
- You have to do some stretch.
I have a massage board
to make for my hands,
do stretch like that.
- Do you wear, like, those wrist guards
that I see some animators wearing?
- No, not me.
But yeah, every one, two hours
I have to do some stretch.
'Cause sitting...
And you also have a good seat.
- Do you have a good gamer chair at home?
- I don't remember the brand, but yeah.
But in fact I'm working on tablet.
So unfortunately I can not be like that.
- [Connor] Oh, you're like hunched over?
- So I'm like.
(everyone laughs)
- Don't forget the microphone by the way.
- Sorry.
- I guess it's the same kind
of precautions a lot of,
let's say like professional gamers
and e-sports athletes have to go through
'cause you're doing a lot
of movements on your wrist.
- Carpal tunnel.
- Yeah, so sometimes I have pain here.
- [Connor] Oh no.
- Yeah, so in fact animators have to do,
so I did something I went
to gym with my friend Medi
and to do some-
- Lift some weights?
- Because yes, you lose muscles.
- Yeah, I definitely feel
doing YouTube as well
'cause I'm sat at my desk all day.
I gotta do something.
- With corona, so now you,
yeah, you don't leave much
or don't move much.
- To the desk, to the fridge.
(everyone laughs)
- As like a teenager sitting at your desk
playing video games all day
and all night or whatever,
you never think about,
oh, what are the ergonomics right now?
You never think about that.
- What part of my body
am I injuring slowly?
- Exactly.
- I did feel bad 'cause I
used to play games, like,
you know, pretty much from
after school till I went to bed
and I never had any problems,
and my other friend would
play like two hours a night
if he was lucky and he got carpal tunnel.
- Oh Jesus.
- And I was like, you're weak.
(everyone laughs)
Real gamers don't listen to that.
- You ain't a pro gamer.
Look at those weak wrists.
Get out of here.
Those aren't gamer wrists.
Get some real thumbs.
- I was just like, worried.
I'm like, why are my wrists not giving in
if this man's are giving in?
- You have some, like, Chad wrists.
- Maybe I came out the womb with just-
- The thickest wrists.
(everyone laughs)
- Natural selection, like,
chose you in the wrong way.
- My kid is gonna have,
like, jacked wrists.
(everyone laughs)
Natural selection is gonna thicken.
Oh my God.
- Yeah, so most of when you are young,
you can stay a little more
longer just at your work hard.
But when you get older,
you have now a family, kids, and-
- You can't afford to
just stay there all day.
- Go back to home.
- No wonder your sempais can draw so fast.
They need to.
- And he was trained to so.
And there was this pressure
and those deadlines make them more faster.
Faster but and good, you have the quality.
- Yeah.
- But sometimes when you
not have much experience,
you have to get faster
and some time you have
to sacrifice the quality.
- And I suppose are those the scenes
that kind of always
get memed on on Twitter
and social media and stuff like that?
- Yes.
And there's also, you have
a wild day, a bit of a mess.
Some because of the
communication wasn't good
with the assistant production.
The animator didn't have time to do it.
Or the animator couldn't do it.
Okay, we have nobody.
Okay, we give it to China, Korea to do it.
And China, Korea.
Oh, we don't have time.
We have to speed it.
- "Seven Deadly Sins."
It depends also which studio will do it.
Because sometimes you have a gloss name.
So for example, you have
studio A will do it,
all the episode of 12 episode.
Oh, we don't have much time.
We have to do, we do just 10 episodes.
And the two will be done
by different studios.
We asked studio B and C
to do each one episode.
And if B and C don't have the good stuff.
- It looks bad.
- You have some accident.
And also more than the studio,
you should more look at the staff.
The studio is like a share.
- It's the staff that mattered the most.
- The studio will give a good environment
for a good working place for the animators
and good assistant productions.
But all the skills
and all the staff will
be all in freelance.
So it's a studio who, okay,
you can do this project
and we can give you a good working place.
- 'Cause I've always wondered
'cause, you know, there's
always like the meme
in our community where
if an episode is animated
well versus an episode
that's animated bad,
we always talk about like,
"Oh, it's the budget."
You know, "They're not
given enough budget."
But like, how true is that?
Is that actually reflected?
Or like, is it, do they have,
is it all about the
staff that they can hire?
And the staff there?
- Most of the staff.
A lot of things in fact.
You have also the budget,
but for example, you have an episode.
You have lot of action,
a lot of movements.
Actually one episode is 350 cuts.
But for some, a lot of heavy
episode, a lot of action,
epic episode can have 500 cuts.
So for this episode it would be-
- More expensive.
Per cut.
- Per cut.
But for the next episode,
you have to adjust to this.
- Right, right, right, right.
- So if you had the
climax on episode seven,
so maybe episode eight will be more cool.
- And you talked about some
animators being more experienced
and more skilled and like have
making a name for themselves.
Can they negotiate a higher price per cut?
- Yeah, yeah.
Actually, so their rate of the cut is
when you have the offer,
they said, "The rate of the cut is this."
So most of the series is a 4,500 yen.
So, I don't know-
- $45 roughly.
For one cut?
- One cut.
One cut can take you
like one day, two days.
It all depends.
- Oh God.
$45 for two days of work.
- Sometimes it can take you one week.
- I know a great website called Fiverr.
(everyone laughs)
- So like, you can ask, "Excuse me."
You try to negotiate.
- I wanna live.
- Excuse me, what the fuck?
(everyone laughs)
- My rent is this much.
- You have to negotiate for this cut.
"It's a bit heavy cut.
"Can you put it twice?
"Twice the price or three
times the price, please."
You have to negotiate.
And sometimes if you are very, very famous
like we call this a super
animator, like a one man army.
You say, "My rate is this."
They want you.
- You just gotta put
your dick on the table.
- If you are very famous,
like a veteran animator.
They have the name value.
Because he's in the show,
people want to look it.
- Right.
- So that's kind of how, like,
it works with YouTubers too.
It's like if you're a famous YouTuber
that has so much years of experience,
then you can just be like, yeah, you know.
- Honestly if you've
made a name for yourself,
you deserve a higher cut.
- Actually we can say that
it's a bit like soccer teams
when you're, "Oh, I want to want Renaldo."
- Right, you gotta pay the money.
- Is that why, whenever you see, like,
the climax of a big scene
especially in like some
shonen anime or like some big,
you always see the same
names animating those.
- Same names?
Yes.
Or some new ones.
Because you can not,
only have some few names.
So you have to find new talent.
- Are they constantly
looking for new animators?
- Always, always
- Yeah.
Yeah, I guess it's 'cause if
you're not getting paid, like,
a lot it's hard to find
people who would do it, right?
- Yeah.
Actually if you're too expensive,
so, "Okay, we don't have the budget."
We're gonna find someone else.
- You mentioned Twitter as well.
Is that how they find a
lot of the newer talent?
- Twitter also, because
now we're on Twitter.
I think, you know, the web generation.
Some quite a friend
animators who yeah, welcome.
Pretty, pretty much.
- I'm just wondering.
So is there this much of a
shortage of animators in Japan
that they have to look
literally on Twitter?
They're doing what we do
and just browsing Twitter
and being like you seem
to have a good portfolio.
- Or by your recommendation
by your senpai.
"Oh, I had worked with this young guy.
"He's pretty skillful.
"Or I will have worked with this.
"We had some problem, but you
can manage to work on it."
So it depends.
If you work with a friend,
people you know that they
are learning by themself.
By themself.
And they're doing all
the best as they want.
And they accepted the amount of money.
And so if there is an accident,
it's normal because they
are learning by theirself.
And you have to teach
them how to get better.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah 'cause I actually
have like an artist friend
who used to like draw
stuff for me years ago
who ended up being an
animator for "Black Clover."
- Yeah, same here.
Like, I had a, like an
artist who I was following
and an animator
and then they just showed up
working on "Sword Art Online."
Shout out to K Animations.
- It's just weird how that,
like, I didn't think, like,
I'd always heard of like
the web gen animators
as we call them.
But like I've never actually,
like, seen it happen.
So when I saw it happen,
I was like, "Oh, wow.
"They actually use Twitter as
like a form of auditioning."
- Yeah, exactly.
- I think the flashpoint
we can take, like,
was maybe at "Boruto."
Episode 65.
You have a-
- Oh, that fight.
That fight!
It's the moment Sasuke,
Sasuke and Naruto versus Momoshiki, right?
- Yeah.
And in fact, the director was Sikigo San,
and he's a Chinese guy who success
to call a lot of the foreign animators.
And he was by himself for
doing the assistant projects
by himself, trying to
contact a lot of animators,
check the data to put some correction.
And I think he had spent
two months at the studio,
but because of him,
he could manage a lot of animators to work
on this episode.
And episode 65 of "Baruto"
was a masterclass.
- Yeah, I mean, that
was my favorite fight.
- I've seen the fight.
I don't know anything but I-
- No, I haven't seen "Baruto."
I've just seen that fight.
And that was by far the
best fight of the year
in my opinion.
- And with this episode is proof,
okay, foreign animators can
also work on Japanese animation.
But you have problems about communication.
You have some staff who
have to speak English
or if they can speak Japanese, it's okay.
Or sometimes you have some mistakes,
but yes if you work with foreign,
it's happened,
but if you correct them
and they do their best.
- What would you say is the best way
for let's say a young
animator to get involved
in the anime industry now?
- Well, like I said, it depends
the experience you want.
If you just want to work on
one piece or just once, okay
Twitter will be okay, I think.
Or I want just a one year experience.
Okay, let's see. If you
want to come to Japan
you have to find a studio
could prove you a visa.
- Lot of law hoops to jump through.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And if you want a career,
"I want to work in Japan,
"I want to live in Japan,
"I want to marry the Japanese girl."
(everyone laughs)
- "I want that ideal weeb lifestyle."
- And so
- Bold of you to assume
you're gonna have enough time
and money to marry a
Japanese girl as an animator.
- I was thinking of asking,
but I don't know how personal it is.
'Cause you mentioned that
like obviously the senpais
they have a family and whatnot.
How the fuck does anyone date?
(everyone laughs)
Because it sounds like you
guys never leave the office.
How do you date? Do you
bring them to the office?
"You're like, hold on.
"I'm gonna do a key frame."
- It actually is like that.
(everyone laughs)
- Have you ever brought
a date to the office?
- No, no, not me.
Actually, yes, so I'm
working at the studio
and also sometime I'm working
on two shows at the same time.
So I'm working on the movie and sometimes-
- Again, how do you find the time?
- Unless you're dating,
like, another key animator.
- She's two blocks down.
- She's like three tables away.
- Actually I prefer to
not date at the workplace.
- Don't shit where you eat.
- Speaking about animations for going
to a bit kill my passion I will say.
I prefer to talk of other things.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- I mean, you have the
love of your life revolving
around animation, I'm
sure you want a break.
- Because I'm thinking animation,
I walk animation, I shit animation.
(everyone laughs)
- That's the thing, right,
it's like you're doing
so much with animation.
So it's like how do you
find time to be like,
"You know what?
"Today I'm just gonna go out of town."
- Do you get a lot of downtime?
- Yes, yes, yes.
Because now, like I said,
so the few years hard,
but after you can manage with the studio
to have a kosaku.
And kosaku is mean a fixed
contract you can say.
And you can get paid per months.
- Okay.
- A salary.
(everyone laughs)
You can negotiate to get the salary.
- So, you have to prove yourself, okay.
So, you at first-
- You have to prove
yourself to get a salary.
- This is so bizarre.
- Because like I said, yeah.
All the salary or the
money is by self taught.
- You have to prove your worth.
- You don't sign contracts.
- Oh really?
- You get paid this amount,
but you say nothing is
reduced by speaking.
- So it's all verbal?
- Yes or by mail.
- Do you get it like in cash or like what?
- By bank.
- Bank transfer.
- The bank doesn't ask questions?
The bank believes you?
"No, trust me, we had a deal."
- It's freelance in Japan.
- But that kind of goes completely
against what we talked about
with like Twitter artists.
It's like, you have to
like sign a contract
and like get an NDA and all that shit
just to like protect you.
Where in Japan it's just like,
"Yeah, we promise we'll give you this."
- I have more security
buying something off eBay.
Jesus Christ.
- You're don't sign NDA in Japan.
- You can come here and
talk about the things
that you worked on.
- I mean, technically he could.
- I mean, you were telling it's all based
on the trust system.
Is this true even for when they, like,
contact a random Twitter animator
and ask them to work on a new project?
It's not under NDA or anything like that?
- They trust you.
(Garnt laughs)
- So, that animator who
could say no and be like,
"Guys, I know the next
movie that's coming out."
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
- How has there not been,
like, a leak every week?
- Because the trust of the
studio and the animators.
And if you have some leaks,
you can just black list it.
- Yeah, true, true.
- And if you get blacklisted
you'd find no more works.
- Yeah.
- So, yeah.
- That's crazy.
- It's up to you.
(everyone laughs)
- Don't fuck it up.
- Yeah, just don't fuck up.
- I'm surprised there hasn't
been like just one person,
one rogue animator hasn't popped up
in the entire history of anime.
That's impressive.
- If you mess up, you're telling
big names what've you done.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jesus.
- And I guess it would make sense
'cause a lot of these people
look up to the directors
and the people in charge, so
I doubt they would try and-
- I guess it'd be like
backstabbing your idol.
- Right, the thing that you love.
So at least that makes sense.
- I guess, do you want
to talk about the thing
that all three of us
have been wanting to ask?
- Yeah, I mean, as an animator on Twitter
and everything like that.
- Your opinion matters.
- Yeah, your opinion matters.
- Our opinion doesn't mean shit.
Your opinion on the other
hand, it means a lot.
- Like, how do you feel about, you know,
artists and animators getting backlash
after an episode has aired.
- [Connor] For example, "Attack on Titan."
Just say it Garnt.
(everyone laughs)
For some reason people
are very, very angry
and have been sending even,
I think, death threats.
- Yeah, to directors
and animators on Twitter
and stuff like that.
- Does that scare you
or anything like that?
Working on projects and-
- Well, if I had those kind of threats,
I'd be, "Oh, I messed up that."
(everyone laughs)
- No, no!
No, no, you shouldn't feel like that.
- Actually in my case,
it's just Twitter internet.
I don't have time to bother about that.
I have to concentrate on my drawings.
(everyone laughs)
- Too busy doing work.
Yeah, exactly.
- So, yeah, but for people
who gave up all their guts
and didn't sleep, managed
to deliver the episode,
and receive all the threats, it's a bit-
- I feel like they don't get paid enough
to deal with threats.
(everyone laughs)
You know, hard work.
- Yeah, and I think most of animators know
they're working up.
I couldn't done this well,
but I managed to do it.
They know their level and
they want to progress to good.
Everybody wants to do a good episode,
want to make a quality.
But you have to manage it
with the amount of scheduled,
the amount of money.
And yes, it's very hard.
And sometime you, as I mentioned,
a good schedule,
there's something going
well doesn't exist.
You have a lot of programs
you have to adjust.
- It's not just like the
problem of like, you know,
the single animator, right.
It's like, there's a lot of things
that the animator probably has to juggle.
But like, if I like, you
know, but say for example,
like, I would maybe
understand a little more
if even the animator
looked at what they did
and was like, "Yeah, that
wasn't my best work."
But this is "Attack on
Titan" we're talking about.
And it's been pretty amazing so far.
- Have you been following the
episodes of "Attack on Titan?"
- Yes, I have watched the last one.
- People are for some reason
very vocal about like,
"Oh, it's terrible now.
"The animation quality is terrible."
- Most of the people don't
like the CGI, I think, yeah.
And yeah, if you are used to something
that you wish that you had done.
And now it's with CGI.
Actually me too when I
see, oh, this season's CGI.
I prefer it was more sakuga.
I understand.
- But you can say that because
you're in the industry.
- Yeah, I understand that.
Some of them say, "Oh, it's CGI.
"I prefer sakuga."
But it's not a reason to-
- Yeah, it's not a reason to death threat.
- People are like, "The show is ruined.
"The CGI has ruined my show."
And it's like, what do you mean?
It's so bizarre.
- But like, people are also complaining
about some of the sakuga as well.
- Really?
- Yeah, I've been seeing
that, like, you know,
I've seen some people on Twitter-
- They've been awesome though.
- Yeah, I know.
Some people on Twitter have,
you know, like done comparisons
with like the manga panels, for example.
And being like, "It's completely ruined!
"It's not exactly the same."
Like, how do you feel
about stuff like that?
(Ken sighs)
- They push too much.
(everyone laughs)
- 'Cause I've always wondered
'cause you've worked on some
pretty high profile shows.
- "My Hero" had this problem as well.
- "My Hero" had this problem a lot.
- Do you ever, like, when working on it,
do you ever like feel the pressure
whenever you're working on a big IP?
Like, you need to and want to deliver?
- Actually, I know that most of,
when I post something
of my genga on Twitter,
it's not my animation that have likes,
it's more the IP has likes.
- Right, right, right.
- I think people don't, I don't know,
most of the people puts
a like or the retweet
because it's my, I like this IP.
- Yeah, no-
- "Jojo" fans, right?
- I did see on your Twitter.
- Actually yeah, I think
it was my "Jojo" genga-
- Of course it was!
- Had the most retweets.
- Was it the Pesci?
'Cause I think I saw the
animation that you did for that.
- Yeah, Bucciarati versus Pesci.
- I love that!
That's like literally like
the best fight in part four,
like so good, it was amazing.
- It was so hard to-
(everyone laughs)
Because it was in 2018.
It was Christmas.
And I spent all my Christmas
and New Year working
at the studio.
I spent three weeks sleeping
at the studio to finish.
- Three weeks sleeping at the studio?
- Yeah.
- For the Pesci fight?
- Well, because I had to
finish the "Hero Aca" layout
and after "Hero Aca" I had my-
- Wait, so you were working
on the "Hero Aca" layout
while you're working on the "Jojo" genga?
- When I finished "Hero
Aca," "Jojo" came back.
(everyone laughs)
And the deadline was
like the 10th of January.
And so most of my coworkers
went to what was a Tapiko.
So most of it was French people.
So they went back to France.
I spend the new year and I came back,
and when they went to France,
I had no beard and when they
came back I had a big beard.
(everyone laughs)
- Just haven't left the office.
- I haven't left the office.
- Just, like, became a hermit.
(everyone laughs)
- And so I was going to
go gym to have my shower.
(everyone laughs)
- Oh my God.
- So, that must have been
like the case where like
if you were there all the
time, you're probably like,
were you just thinking about
it in the shower as well?
You're like thinking
about what you were going
to draw next as well?
- Yeah, shower takes time,
but sometimes you can itch or I smell bad.
I have to take a shower
- You gotta optimize your showers.
It's just like, do you
ever get to the point
when you're just like eating?
Too much time.
- I was eating, watching an episode,
eating and okay, episode finished.
I finish to eat.
Okay, go back to work.
- Jesus.
- You're welcome "Jojo" fans.
(everyone laughs)
- You're welcome anime fans.
- And so, yes, I get sick also.
I think I had, eat a bad
one or I have influenza,
how do you say in English?
- You had influenza?
- Yeah, I get influenza this time.
- You got flu.
- I was working like that.
(Ken groans)
- Literally killing
yourself for "Jojo" fans.
- You can say you were.
(everyone laughs)
I think you can say it.
- I was trying to do my best on this one.
- I think a lot of people would argue
that's one of the best
fight scenes in part five.
It looks amazing as well.
- I think all of part
five, everyone could tell-
- Not just saying that 'cause
you're here. (everyone laughs)
- Yeah, no, it's definitely
a crowd favorite.
- Like I said, animations is a teamwork.
So like I said, I do the rough animation
after the director put some correction.
So something that was a
too little, how can I say?
Oh, you can push more this arm.
The director will put it in.
After the director of animation
will put more in model.
And so these three tips
are very important.
After I have received this
correction, I redraw it,
everything with all the detail,
all the shadows, all the
light, all the perfect frames.
So yes, it's a teamwork.
And after these drawings,
it will be the in-betweener
who will cleanup.
And it's a very teamwork.
It's not just one animator's work,
it's you have the director,
the director of animation,
the in-betweener, the color.
- I'm curious, this is
gonna be a dumb question.
Do you like hear, when you're drawing it,
I assume is the voice acting
recorded at that point?
Or is it not recorded?
- No, it's way after.
- Way after?
Oh, wow.
- The voice acting is post-production.
- Oh, wow. So you don't even
get to, like, hear the lines
as you're drawing or anything.
- Sometimes you have some rough voice.
But it's not the final voice.
- It's mostly just, like,
I think it's written out in
the layout section, right?
Of what the actual what they're gonna say
in this particular-
- The storyboard.
And after you have the time sheet
when at this moment you have to.
- And then the voice actors match that.
- Yeah.
- So all anime is dubbed anime.
- Yeah, it is dubbed.
(everyone laughs)
- Wow.
- Checkmate, sub-elitists.
(everyone laughs)
I've always been curious
because obviously like you work
on a lot of shonen jump properties
and that's obviously based on
like adapting manga panels.
As an animator, do you ever like look
at the manga panels of, like,
the cut you're animating?
Or do you just try to go in fresh?
- Yeah, of course. So
when I do the meetings,
I have the manga on my side
because they have print manga.
- Okay.
- Your scene will be on
this part of the manga.
They give it to me.
And so, yes, it's important
to read a bit of the manga
because you more know
how is the characters.
And also when you speak with the director,
he will say so this
character is more calm.
He doesn't have much expression.
And so don't,
less cold man, ice face.
- I guess you got to know the
personality of the character
to know how they-
- Yes.
So if you have read the
manga, it's a good job
because, well, the director will be,
"Oh, he has read the manga,
so he knows the show."
- [Connor] Right, that makes sense.
- So all animators are manga readers.
- No, it depends.
Some times I didn't.
Wait, I read everything.
(everyone laughs)
- Just proving your own point.
- My buddy Medi hadn't read the show.
And so we bet he walked out on it so-so.
- I guess then in that sense,
I guess like anime
originals must be so hard,
so much harder because there's no-
- Oh yeah, there's no reference point.
- Like, light novels I guess even.
- But even still, right?
Like, light novels would be
even harder because you gotta-
- It's just all words.
- It's all text.
- If you want a good fact,
when I was working on
"Dragon Ball Super Broly"
I didn't know it was Broly.
- Oh, really?
- Who'd you think it was?
- I was working on the "Dragon Ball" movie
but I didn't know it was the bad guy.
(everyone laughs)
- 'Cause you didn't read it.
- No because he didn't say to me.
- Oh, they're just like, "Draw this."
- Wait, they kept the fact
that Broly was a bad guy
from the animators?
- It was a secret that
I didn't know the title
of the show was "Broly."
- Oh, so you animated that
without even knowing the
context of the entire cut.
- Yeah.
- You were just like, "Oh, sick, Broly!"
(everyone laughs)
- Because I have phone-
- That sounds insane.
- Because my cut was just
Vegeta was going against Goku.
- Oh, okay.
- So, yes, and I think
they didn't want some leaks
about Broly.
- I mean, that makes sense.
- I mean, you know, they
could also just sign an NDA.
(everyone laughs)
- What?
- Never heard of it.
- I'm curious, this is
just such a vague question.
What is your like top anime
shows for you personally?
- Original anime show?
- Anything.
- I prefer to talk about original anime
because, well, when it's adaptation,
you have multiple of the manga.
So maybe, I like "Evangelion" like I said,
and "Gurren Lagann."
- "Gurren Lagann," of course.
- It's just a little like guy next trio.
- Because they had the power
to do original animation
and it was great.
After I don't watch much
of them, much shows before.
- Too busy making them.
- And also when you ask
"Oh, what's your top 10?"
You forgot.
- No, we're exactly the same.
- I put you on the spot, I'm sorry.
- I do want to know though
as an animator are there any, like, scenes
or any animation cuts
that you really look up to
and you, like, idolize as
legendary and have inspired you?
- Yeah.
Like, you have a lot of animation of,
"Wow, how he make these movements?"
And so, yeah, when you're
doing frame per frame
when you're animator,
watch the movement.
Okay, oh, this frame is
just exposed at one, two.
Oh, this frame, is exposed at three.
And oh, at this moment you
have the fire come here.
And you analyze the movement
like that frame by frame.
Every animator's doing like that.
And so, oh, so this is the key animation.
- So, you watch the anime really slow.
(everyone laughs)
- At first I watch the
anime like everybody.
Whoa, what was his movement?
So I put a stop and frame
by frame by frame by frame.
- I guess like an animator
or I guess like director
that comes to mind when it comes to, like,
amazing animation would be
like Satoshi Kon, right?
- Yeah.
You know Kon Satoshi.
- Like, Kon Satoshi, like, he
managed to animate in a way,
because I think I saw it in
some kind of interview with him,
like way before,
that, like, the reason why
he went into animation was
because his way of directing
is too fast for live action.
- Yeah.
- So, whereas like,
because there's so many cuts in Kon movies
where it's just, it's like a blink.
It's so fast, it's almost subliminal
that you just can't
replicate in live action.
And he's just, I dunno.
Like, even I'm not an
animator at all or anything
but like you can watch a
Satoshi Kon movie and be like,
how do you even think to
animate something like that?
- I have one of my senpai who had worked
on a Kon Satoshi movie.
It was the co-director
of "Tokyo Godfathers."
- Oh wow.
- His name is Furuya Shogo.
And yeah, the Kon movies
are very realistic.
Realistic in the
character, the expression.
In "Millennium Actress,"
the way he mix up the fiction
and reality is so good.
- It's like the scene transitions.
It's just like nuts.
- And you can watch it every time and,
oh, this cut connects with this cut.
And also I like "Tokyo Godfathers"
because I dunno, it's a
movie you want to watch
at Christmas.
- It's one of the few
Christmas anime movies, I feel.
Not that it was meant to
be a Christmas anime movie.
It just happens to be on Christmas.
- And yeah, but one, my senpai
said Kon Satoshi was one
of the best maybe best anime.
- Oh yeah.
- He's really, really fast.
And he have a perfect brain.
(Connor laughs)
- Yeah, because I think I saw that, like,
Satoshi Kon used to like draw
some of his own animations
as well.
He was key animator of his own show.
- Because he have done mangaka.
Yes, he was manga.
Lot of work with Katsuhiro Otomo.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so yeah, I don't
know if he have work
on "Akira" or not.
I don't remember.
But yes, he was very close with Otomo
with those generation of artists
who was a lot of movie makers in Japan.
- As an animator, what do you think
of like "Akira" for
instance, like the animation?
- "Akira" is amazing animation.
- Because I feel that like,
when people say "Akira,"
they're just like, yeah,
this animation hasn't aged.
Like, it aged so well.
- If you want a bit for
animators, good animation,
you have so "Jin-Roh."
- "Jin-Roh."
- I've heard that's pretty legendary.
- For my senpai he said that
"Jin-Roh" is to animation,
realistic the most extreme.
Too much extreme that most
of the animators is just
for masturbation of animation.
(everyone laughs)
It's too much.
But he said, it's a
good entertainment one.
And with the good animation
or so very pushed was "Memories."
- [Joey] The ultima Katsuhiro.
- And you have the "Magnetic Rose."
- "Magnetic Rose" is so good.
- I don't know any of these.
- Each plan of "Magnetic Rose"
of animation is a masterclass.
Because most of the frames
are exposition of three frame.
Less frame but just good
drawings, good timings.
- "Magnetic Rose" if
you don't know is, like,
a space opera "Akira."
That's the only way to describe it.
- How old is it?
It's like from the 90s?
Like, late 90s.
It was quite a while after,
but it's like, "Magnetic
Rose" is like a short film
that Otomo Katsuhiro directed.
- It's like 40 minute-
- It's like a 40 minute short film,
but it's like, yeah,
it's basically just space
opera "Akira" is the only way
to describe it, but it's fucking amazing.
- And with the same
team of "Magnetic Rose,"
you have a "Hashire Melos," "Run, Melos."
I didn't to watch it
but I had watched some
cuts of "Hashire Melo"
and it was very impressive.
So yeah.
- So I guess if you want to be
an animator just study those.
- This is the realist ones,
the golden age of animators, we say.
- It's interesting
hearing an actual opinion
from an actual animator.
'Cause you know, whenever
we think of like,
oh, what do we think is the best animated
whatever or anime of all time?
Like, most people would say
like "Redline" probably.
The one that comes to my mind.
- Definitely.
- Do you think that,
what's your opinion about
like older anime versus, like,
newer digitized anime?
- Yeah.
Well, digital animation
is you can get quicker
because we can work at to your place
and send by mail or the datas.
It's not paper.
You don't have to scan it.
But the program offered
the animation industry
to most of, like I said,
sakans, animation director.
Most of them are on paper.
- Because they've been in
the industry for so long.
- So long and they would like
to learn some digital animation,
but they don't have the time.
Yeah, or they don't care.
- Paper is superior.
- I work in 10 years and will die so.
(everyone laughs)
- I'll die doing animation on paper!
- I learned animation on paper,
I will die doing animation on paper.
- Some of my senpai have tried
to learn digital animation,
but he was too much stress
that he have a pain on stomach.
Had to go to hospital.
- Oh God.
(everyone laughs)
- That's horrible, but I just
have to laugh about that.
- So yeah, so me I'm doing digital.
And so I'm doing my layout in digital.
But if the sakan have to
check it, put correction,
they have to print it and put correction.
- And then fax it back to you.
- Yeah.
(everyone laughs)
- That was a joke, right?
- This wasn't a joke.
(everyone laughs)
- I was joking, oh God.
- Because they have the
correction is on paper.
No, no, sorry, but they have to print it.
They scan it.
They scan it to send it me back by data.
And for me to doing it digital.
So yeah, so most of the
in-betweens are digital,
but it depends.
So digital and paper are a bit.
I think more veterans and good
animators are still on paper.
Nowadays some youngs are more on digital,
but the problem is software.
You have to pay it.
And most of the software are expensive.
- Commercial licenses are very expensive.
- And also, you know how
much animators are paid.
There is good stuff like
TVPaint, but it's too expensive.
So yeah.
- I can't believe the
software's, like, too expensive
for the people who are
gonna use the software.
For the people who are
going to use the software
for what it was designed to do.
- It's like, "Sorry, man,
we want to pay you more,
"but Photoshop is like
$60 a month, you know?
"It's kind of expensive."
- A lot of now, young animators
are working on Blender
because Blender is free.
It's free and you can
do 3D and 2D animation
at the same time.
And I think-
- I thought that was just
a meme. (everyone laughs)
So, people in the anime industry
are actually using Blender?
- Some of them.
Not everybody.
- I guess the meme had
to come from somewhere.
(everyone laughs)
- 'Cause it's like a meme now
whenever we see something bad,
it's like, "Oh, this looks like
it was animated in Blender."
Didn't think there was
any reality to that.
- All the animators.
(everyone laughs)
Shit.
Slowly closes Blender.
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, in fact the stuff
doesn't the big point.
If you put it has a still on like a paper.
Because the correction would
be on paper or on digital,
but because each you, if it's on JPEG,
every soft can open a JPEG.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm curious being an
animator because, like,
we do anime videos on
YouTube and talk about anime.
And as someone who watches anime as a job,
I cannot like, I still enjoy anime,
but I can't enjoy anime the
same way I used to as a kid.
As someone who actually works on anime,
has it changed your view of anime at all
and how you watch it and
everything like that?
- Actually some of my friends
nowadays watch less and less animation.
And they are more critics.
- Right, right, right.
- That does tend to happen.
- I can't imagine an animator
casually sitting down
to watch an anime.
- I can't wait for my favorite season
of "Seven Deadly sins."
- And-
(everyone laughs)
- what did you think about that?
- Sorry, I just watched the first season.
- Okay, okay.
- Oh, have you seen
pictures of season three?
- I've seen on Twitter, yeah.
(everyone laughs)
- Do I need to ask your
opinion or is it obvious?
- Yeah, I understand your feelings.
(everyone laughs)
- I love meming it.
It's just like a disaster.
Like, how did it happen?
- Like I said, maybe it was a gloss
that they asked another studio.
Maybe they didn't have a
sakan, a animation director.
Like I said,
if you have a good animation
director, it can change-
- Everything.
- It got fixed in the
Blu-ray though, right?
- Did it?
I don't think so.
- I think.
- It must be redone from the ground up.
Like, at what point do you just be like,
"All right, just don't
air it. "Don't air this.
"Just redo it.
"Like, just start over please."
Sorry, what were we saying?
I interrupted, sorry.
Oh, critics of the-
- Critics.
Yeah, but now when I watch anime,
I look more about the
technique, how they made that.
"Wow, how'd he do that?"
Like, I do frame by frame.
But also when you watch
too much animation now,
you know the pattern.
Okay, the guy, it's a isekai.
If you watch two, three isekai.
you know how it will finish.
- I feel called out now.
(everyone laughs)
- I guess for animators it's just, like,
watching anime is just like
study material, isn't it?
- Yeah, for most of us animators.
Now, one of my senpai, he said,
"I don't watch anime.
"Now I'm more watching live movies."
And if I watch anime, I'm
watching animation of Honda
or Innosan.
I think it's maybe the
best animators in Japan.
- Kind of to see where the benchmark is.
- You know, Innosan's
nickname is the machine.
- The machine.
Jesus.
- What is Innosan worked on?
- He's one of the directors
of "Magnetic Rose."
- Basically like VIP of anime.
- Or you have gengashu.
Do you know what is gengashu?
Genga so the key poses, shu, archive.
- So it's like an archive collection.
- A book of key frames.
And a lot of when it's Innosan,
every anime does by it.
Because it's Innosan.
He's the man of it.
- Wow, that's so cool.
- So you have some animators
who are very, very talented
and like Sushio of Trigger,
Nakamura Yutaka of Bones.
Those names are very,
they have put their touch
in animation industry
that now-
- It's like the kind of animes
where even if you're
not exactly like a saku
you can just be like, that's a Sushio.
- Nakamura is a very
famous and young animator.
Using a lot of impact frames.
- Yeah.
I did notice that.
There's a lot of more impact frames.
Like, impact frames is, you know,
in a fight scene where it
has like the kind of negative
of the image where it's like,
you have the fight animation
and then sometimes it would just, like,
go into like the black
and white negative of it
for like a few frames.
I'm pretty sure he
started that trend, right?
- Yeah.
I think he was one the first,
and he's very famous because of his,
it's a debris with the cube form.
- Yeah, so you've definitely
seen some of his fights.
He did a lot of, like, the
"My Hero Academia" fights.
- Every shot of you say on
"My Hero Academia" holy shit,
it's him.
- Okay.
Like the Todoroki versus Bakugo fight.
- [Joey] Like when the ground explodes
and then it's like blocks of ground.
- Oh yeah.
That's cool.
- When it explodes like square blocks.
- He's now very famous
because he puts his touch.
And so most of every young
animators imitate him,
learn from his animation.
- I guess like, you know,
you've probably planned
to do like more stuff.
But like, I guess like,
what's like one anime
that you've looked at or like one created
that you looked at and been
like, "I wish I worked on that."
Is there, like, an anime
where you just, like,
the animation or the
story was just so cool
and you think like, "Man, I
wish I had worked on that."
- I don't know.
It's difficult to put just one.
But for example, I would
like if I had the occasion,
I would like to work,
but now it's finished,
but "Last Day of Ang"
I would like work on it.
In fact, yeah, it depends on my schedule.
If it's possible,
if I have delivered or not,
because if only just a very, very-
- Very few animate.
- I'm missing very, very,
the most strongest animators in Japan.
- Okay.
- Because "Evangelion"
the characters unknowing-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I think.
- Does it hurt when you deny like a job
that you really wanted to
do because of you're skill?
- Yes, I have so much denies.
Some good stuff.
Not announced.
(everyone laughs)
- I'll draw one frame.
- Oh fuck my life!
I want to do it.
But yeah, I also have a girlfriend so.
Like I said, it's a good
balance you have to find.
Your privacy, your work, doing some-
- I'll see you in two months, girlfriend.
(everyone laughs)
- Because some animators
have worked too much
and they was married.
Divorced because.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So yeah, they said me,
"Don't mess like me."
(everyone laughs)
- I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, honey.
I'm married to "My Hero Academia."
(everyone laughs)
Is there any IPs you still want to work on
that you haven't yet?
- Yeah, quite a lot.
I would like to, I actually,
my soldier, I liked Julian.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- And I would like to
work on Jinsuman or so.
Like I said, I like.
- Shonen stuff, right.
- Shonen stuff I like.
- One of those fans.
(everyone laughs)
- But not a big IP or
so, it's good senpai.
Actually I'm working on the movie,
and I like everyone so much.
Yeah.
(everyone laughs)
- Amazing?
- Amazing experience.
- You can learn every day.
That's cool or something.
Man, I don't understand this.
- [Connor] And he'll show you.
- Show you and-
- [Connor] That's so cool.
- Yeah.
It's so much cool.
- Sounds like every animator
is constantly just learning
and training themselves.
- Yeah, we want to improve.
We want to push our limits.
But sometimes you have a
wall and you have to pass it.
But how?
- It sounds like a shonen anime in itself.
(Garnt laughs)
- The office is blasting the you say run.
- Every animator is in their training arc.
- You gotta push past your limits.
- This is a bit like that.
- Carpal tunnel, nonsense.
Push past it.
- Only sitting.
- Arthritis is just a roadblock.
(everyone laughs)
You can get over it.
- So that's why sometimes
I saw you listening
to some music or yeah.
Or listening to some
podcasts of your guys.
- Oh, get out of here.
- You have your own podcast, don't you?
- Yes.
"Anime Was A Mistake."
- Anime was a mistake.
- Why didn't we call our podcast that?
- I don't know.
Because we're not an anime
podcast, Joey, that's why.
- I like Trash Taste.
What do you mean?
- So it's with mid-year
with Showi and Jen,
sorry, French people.
We're talking about our
experience of animation industry,
the good, the bad, and how
to don't redo our mistakes.
And sorry, it's in French.
- So any of the French "Trash
Taste" viewers you can go
and listen to that.
- Link's in the description.
- No doubt it'll be full of information.
- There is quite also a
English podcast of animation,
like Yen Yen by City BM of animation.
All in English.
I think for people who
cannot understand English
for French people which
was good to do French.
- And you have Twitter, right?
- Twitter, Instagram also.
- That'll be all on screen right now
and links in the description.
Please go and follow Ken.
- Yeah.
- Please.
- Please!
(everyone laughs)
- What are you doing already?
Go and follow.
- Look at what he's done.
You deserve the clout.
- He definitely does.
You know, who else deserves the clout?
Our patrons.
- Look at these lovely patrons.
- Shout out to those guys.
- If you'd like to support the show,
then make sure to go over to our Patreon,
Patreon.com/TrashTaste.
Also follow us on Twitter as well.
And the subreddit.
And if you want to-
- We've just hit 100K on our subreddit
Did we mentioned that last time?
- I don't know.
- I don't think we did.
- [Joey] Yeah, so thanks to
all the people on the Reddit
and also make sure to
listen to us on Spotify
if you don't wanna see our faces.
- And "Trash Taste"
episodes will have subtitles
or captions.
So if you do want to listen
to them, they'll have them.
Click on the CC button
if you're interested.
Probably should've said that
at the start of the episode.
- Right?
- But from now on you know.
- Now you know.
- Thank you very much for coming on, Ken.
- Thank you.
- This has been the most educational.
- Probably the most
educational episode we've had.
It feels nice to not have
three buffoons arguing-
- I think this is what
happens in the anime.
(everyone laughs)
- Meilyne, check it up.
Meilyne's the fact checker, right?
She knows everything.
- I'm happy to if I could,
I don't know if it's teaching you,
but a lot of-
- I feel like I've learned.
- I have some information
about the backstage.
- Yeah.
- One episode is a lot of work,
a lot of people who work on it
and sleepless night and overworks.
But for quality in doing
everybody all doing the best.
- I mean, the work
speaks for itself, right?
- Give love to the animators
that's the bottom line.
- Basically.
And anyway, that's been this
episode of "Trash Taste."
Hope you guys enjoyed it and
we will see you next time.
- You fucked up.
- I know.
I was like stumbling there.
(chill music plays)